now we're gonna do some country star
confessions okay ready okay country star
confessors with Dustin Lynch here we go
[Music]
[Music]
it's not that bad
well I mean I'm look here we go what is
your go-to karaoke song go-to karaoke
song without a doubt it's forgot about
Dre by dr. dre nem Anil why you think
they have to think about that well
that's my gosh
do you know it even off the top your
head absolutely I know all the words
give me a little bit just give me like
two hours nowadays everybody want to
talk that they got something to say but
nothing comes out when they move the
lips just to put your different bits
your ultimate cheat meal ultimate cheat
meal hmm some sort of gigantic Italian
food okay like pasta
oh I mean I'll start with pizza and then
just go down the deep end a lot of pasta
um
Taron finished it with some tiramisu
okay no go to bed
[Music]
[Music]
what is your most prized possession Wow
um my most prized possession is my Grand
Old Opry trophy case
oh that's good yeah I've got that now I
mean just crazy to be a member of the
Grand Old Opry but they allow you to
take home a trophy it's actually got
part of the original circle oh there and
then I've got a weird object in that
trophy case Reba McEntire inducted me Oh
made it officials who surprised me and
whenever she came out she was saying
such sweet things about me and the Opry
that I started crying that she started
crying so she ran offstage and grabbed
tissues and brought them back to me and
I have those in my shirt got some snotty
tissues they rigged it gave me a good
job who was your first celebrity crush
pardon okay great segue first celebrity
and we've become friends over the years
and she's so sweet I can't believe
someone that that's had that much
success before I was living and still is
it's still at the top of her game it's
so humble and so kind to like reach out
congratulate me via email whenever I'm
having success or ever it's just nuts
he's just awesome person
the country
[Music]
when was the last time you cried
watching TV oh gosh you know what I get
very emotional watching acceptance
speeches at award shows so it was
probably Grammys or Oscars uh yeah it
was probably whatever whatever whatever
musical workshop watched last you know I
get very inspired by acceptance speeches
um and also I think I get variants but
like Super Bowl speeches or any of the
like you know the football national
chain because those guys are just
tackled the biggest feat in our lives
and yeah anything like that inspired
gets me gets me emotional
[Music]
what is your biggest fear biggest fear
is Heights okay but I will say I've kind
of getting better with that I've been up
in mountain climbing a little bit oh I'm
getting better but I guess the
reoccurring dream that I have is
probably my biggest fear cuz I keep
dreaming about it as me not knowing the
worst of my songs on stage
oh yeah it's that first singer yeah and
it's so weird it's never that I don't
know him it's that I'd know him after
I'm supposed to sing them something on
line behind happens all the time and I
don't know what that means but well cuz
people always have to dream like they
haven't studied for an exam or something
like that maybe what it is like a
translation for a singer would be yeah
it used to be that I was naked on stage
and that's transition that I don't know
what happened there there's nothing
going on there was that was it hey I'm
Graham Anil for more on your favorite
country stars click Subscribe or watch
the videos over there
[Music]